[MUSIC PLAYING]
And all of you here are
in for a treat today.
Sam Gralla, who I'm
very impressed with,
is going to tell us about one
of the most amazing things
that science has
done in a long time.
And that's the measurement
of gravity waves.
And he will describe it to us,
and at the end of the evening
we'll have a quiz.
[LAUGHTER]
But Sam is a theorist working
on gravitational physics
and relativistic astrophysics.
He's interested in the
strongest gravitational
and electromagnetic
fields in the universe,
which occur near black
holes and neutron stars.
And you heard a little
bit about this last week.
Sam applies techniques
from diverse communities,
relativity, astrophysics,
particle physics
to study the physical
processes occurring
in these extreme environments.
His PhD is from Chicago,
and his postdoctoral work
is from Maryland and Harvard.
And we're really lucky to
have Sam as one of our faculty
members.
Sam, where are you?
[APPLAUSE]
Well, what a pleasure to be
here in this beautiful hall,
in this great university
in this wonderful city.
I'm a newcomer to Tucson.
I've been here less
than two years.
So I thought I'd
start by telling you
the story of how I came to
the University of Arizona.
When you're a young theoretical
physicist, you apply widely
and you hope you get
some interviews--
which, fortunately, I did.
Now, a job interview
for a professor job
is a little different from
a normal job interview.
It's really more like 20
or 30 interviews right
after each other.
You meet with
everybody-- professor
after professor, half
an hour meetings.
You barely have time to pee.
If you're lucky, in
the midst of all this
you get to meet with the dean.
Now, I had a thing I did
with deans on job interviews.
The first thing I would do
when I got in the dean's office
is I'd take out a book
and I'd start reading it.
That would get the
conversation started, usually
with something like,
what are you doing?
And then I'd say, you
tell me one thing--
if you're in a vehicle
moving at the speed of light
and you turn on your
headlights, do they work?
[LAUGHTER]
And Dean [INAUDIBLE]
said the U of A
was the only one who
did not immediately
throw me out of the room.
OK, I made that one up.
That's a recycled
Steven Wright joke.
But the comedian Steven Wright
has his interviewee in his joke
ask a really deep question.
You go at the
speed of light, you
turn on your headlights,
what happens?
This is a good question
for two reasons.
First, it pushes us outside
of our comfort zone, right?
You think you kind
of know how light
works from living with
light all around you,
but as soon as you ask a
question involving where
you're moving like
the speed of light,
you get a little confused.
Maybe you don't
understand light so well,
because you're used to
not moving that fast.
The second reason Steven
Wright's question is a good one
is because it's
reasonably precise.
It's not some vague,
can you make light stop?
It's some pretty precise
sequence of actions.
You get in your car, you
get up to light speed,
and you pull the lever
that would normally
turn the lights on.
What happens?
These kinds of questions
that are reasonably precise
yet push us outside
our comfort zone
are called thought experiments.
And Einstein really
was the pioneer
of the thought experiment.
He called them gedanken
experiments in German.
This is not exactly the
kind of thought experiment
Einstein did, but it's close.
And the answer to this
particular conundrum
was given to us by Einstein.
The answer is you
can't go that fast.
[LAUGHTER]
Seems a little
unsatisfying, but wait.
Einstein didn't mean your
car won't go that fast.
That's not what he meant.
He meant you just
can't go that fast,
nothing can go that fast--
not your car, not a truck,
not a motorcycle, not a
plane, not a spaceship,
not an ambulance,
not a backhoe--
we have lots of those in
my neighborhood right now--
not a garbage truck,
not a fire truck--
I have a two-year-old,
he really likes trucks.
He knows about suction
excavators and so forth.
None of your favorite
desert animals
can go that fast--
coyotes, road runners.
You know those wolf spiders
that seem like they're
going the speed of light?
Those ones can't go that fast.
You can't hit a baseball
that fast, a hockey puck.
No elementary particle can
be accelerated that fast--
absolutely nothing can
go the speed of light.
That's what Einstein taught us.
There's a universal speed limit.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, this speed limit
is not Einstein's limit
where he'll come give you
a ticket if you violate it.
This is a law of nature.
You simply cannot go this fast,
no matter how hard you try.
That seems well and good.
We have the authority of
Einstein to back it up.
But if you were a physicist
around Einstein's time,
you might say, hey,
wait a minute, mister.
That doesn't make any sense,
because of the following.
I don't know about
you guys, but I
have memories from
when I was a kid riding
in the backseat
of my car, parents
driving me on the freeway.
You're watching the
scenery go by, and then
all of a sudden, whoosh,
a car whizzes by you.
Of course, they're just driving
60 miles an hour or so too,
but they're going in
the opposite direction.
So to you, they're going
120 miles per hour.
Then there's a formula,
v equals v1 plus v2,
that if you wanted to, will
tell you how to compute this.
And it's really kind of
indisputable, this formula.
What is speed?
It's how far you go
in how much time.
So if the car up here on the
left is going 60 miles an hour,
and in an hour then he'll
be 60 miles to the right,
and the other car will
then in that same hour
be 60 miles to the
left, so in one hour
the relative distance
is 120 miles.
So they're going
120 miles an hour--
seems obvious.
The person who is
skeptical of Einstein
now says, well,
what if I'm going
at 75% the speed of light?
Now this obvious
formula tells me
that I measured the other
car, [WHOOSH] the one going
by me, moving at 150%
the speed of light,
which is supposed
to be impossible.
So here's another
thought experiment
that seems to reveal
something self-contradictory
about this universal
speed limit.
We now have a situation
that theoretical physics
calls a paradox.
We have two laws that
we really believe,
but they're incompatible.
You can't have the
universal speed limit
and the formula v
equals v1 plus v2.
If you were a lesser
physicist you might think,
OK, well we know v
is v1 plus v2 That's
utterly trivial and obvious,
so Einstein must be wrong.
But if you're
Einstein, you think,
we don't really have any
good experimental evidence
that v equals v1
plus v2 when you're
moving near the speed of light.
We've only done
those experiments
at 60 miles an hour, which
might as well be standing still
compared to light.
So which of these do we keep
and which do we discard?
We keep the speed limit.
It turns out, that
formula is wrong.
Now, as Professor Dienes
emphasized in the first lecture
in this series,
if you were here,
physics doesn't discard laws .
We don't establish laws and
then find out they're false.
Instead, we realize that
certain laws may not
apply as widely as
we thought they did.
In this case, v equals
v1 plus v2 is perfectly
true at 60 miles an hour.
But it is not true near
the speed of light.
And Einstein derived
the correct law.
It's now up there on your right.
You don't have to worry
about the details in the law.
The point is, it reduces to the
old law when you're going slow,
and it's compatible with
the other law of nature.
So we've resolved the paradox.
So now, you're not going
to measure 150% lightspeed.
If you did the measurement,
you would in fact
get 96% lightspeed.
If you actually got
your Doppler radar,
this is what you would measure,
the other car moving relative
to you.
So everything is
happy with the idea
that nothing can go faster
than the speed of light.
So what have we learned?
Is it about cars?
Well, it would also
work for trucks--
[LAUGHTER]
--motorcycles, planes,
spaceships, ambulances,
backhoes, dump trucks, fire
trucks, wheel trenchers,
suction excavators.
All of your favorite desert
animals would observe this law.
All of your favorite balls,
if you played sports,
would observe this law.
Elementary particles.
It's true for everything.
When you think about
it, it's not really
about the stuff of the universe.
This law doesn't care if you're
a Gila monster or a backhoe.
This law is about
something more fundamental.
It's really about
space and time itself.
Now, why do I say that?
Well, think about how
I argued a minute ago
that this original v equals
v1 plus v2 law was so obvious.
I said, well, the
car up there is
going to be 60 miles to
your left after an hour,
and the other car's going to
be 60 miles to your right.
So they're 120 miles
apart in one hour--
120 miles an hour.
That argument gives
a wrong conclusion.
The only slop in
that argument are
the concepts of space
and time, the idea
that if one goes 60 this
way in an hour and the other
goes 60 that way in an
hour, they're now exactly
120 apart in exactly one hour.
That seems obvious to us,
but that's not actually
the way space and time work.
Einstein taught us
that you can't just
add space and time together in
the simple way that you think.
The theme of our lecture
series is rethinking reality.
And this was a big one.
This was 1905,
special relativity.
Einstein really rethought
reality in a big way.
Let me ask you another question.
If I have a feather and a
hammer and I let them go,
which hits the ground first?
Well, in this room, the
feather would float down
and the hammer would go
wham and hit the floor,
maybe damage the stage.
But if we did this
experiment on the moon,
where there's no air--
there's just gravity-- in fact,
the feather and the hammer
would fall at the same rate.
Now, this is something
that has actually
been known about gravity
since the time of Galileo.
But the Apollo astronauts
actually did this on the moon
to dramatize it.
There is actually a video of
dropping a hammer and a feather
on the moon.
So this dramatizes something
that's unfamiliar about gravity
but absolutely true-- that
gravity, like the other laws we
have been talking about, acts
on everything in the same way.
Can you guess what I'm going
to put up on the screen now?
[LAUGHTER]
That's right.
I could drop a truck,
a motorcycle, a plane,
an ambulance, a backhoe, a
Gila monster, a bark scorpion,
and a wolf spider.
They would hit the floor at the
same time if there were no air.
Gravity acts in the
same way on everything.
Now, here's Einstein's
perhaps greatest insight
in a life full of
great insights.
Gravity, since it acts the
same way on everything,
is also somehow not about
the stuff it's acting on.
It's more fundamental.
It too is just about
space and time.
Einstein had this idea,
and five minutes later it
was still an idea, and
10 minutes later it
was still an idea.
And it took him
five or 10 years,
really, to flesh this idea out
and turn it into equations.
And the very first thing he had
to do to flesh this idea out
was to start listening to
his mathematician friend
Hermann Minkowski, who had
been harping on him saying,
no, no, no, time and space
aren't separate in your theory.
In your theory, Einstein, you
should think of time and space
as spacetime.
They need to go together.
So Einstein got on board with
this idea that there should be
spacetime-- three dimensions
of space and one dimension
of time--
and that somehow, gravity
should just be spacetime.
And through much hard
work, he hit on the idea
that what gravity is, is
the curvature of spacetime.
Now, that's a kind of
weird set of words.
Why would he say that?
Well, we all kind of
know what curvature
is for objects in space.
The surface of the
earth is curved,
or I could take a piece of paper
and curve it in front of you.
We'd all agree on
what curvature meant.
And there are
mathematical equations
that have been known
for a long time that
describe the curvature.
What Einstein realized
was that if he
uses the same mathematical
equations that
describe curvature of
two-dimensional sheets of paper
to the four dimensions
of spacetime,
he gets a theory of gravity.
And the equation is up
there on the top right.
So this little cartoon up here
you've seen in other lectures
if you've been coming regularly.
This flexible fabric you
see looks two-dimensional
on the board, on the screen,
but it's just an analogy.
It's supposed to represent that
the four dimensions, all three
of space and time, are curved.
And what makes the
curvature is matter.
So the big red blob in the
middle might be the Sun.
The Sun makes spacetime
curve, and then the Earth
orbiting the Sun,
say that white dot,
just follows the straightest
possible trajectory
in this curved spacetime.
And that makes it go around the
Sun, giving rise to gravity.
Well, this was the hard part.
Once Einstein had
these equations
he had done the hard part
and then the real fun begins.
And at some level, the fun
hasn't stopped since he died.
He and many others
after him, including me,
are working out the amazing
consequences of that equation
on the top right.
And the consequence
I want to tell you
about today is called
gravitational waves.
If you really buy
into the analogy,
it's actually almost
trivial that there
will be gravitational waves.
Because if I wiggled that big
red mass in the middle there,
clearly the fabric
is going to wiggle.
Waves are going to go
out, waves in gravity.
And indeed, Einstein got
that equation in 1915.
And in 1916, one year later,
he had gravitational waves.
Another good analogy
for gravitational waves
is waves on a pond.
I don't know about all of you,
but I don't float very well.
So if I go out in a
pond and try to float,
I end up kind of
thrashing all around
and I look a little bit like
the gentleman in that picture.
There's waves going
out all around me.
Now, if it was a really big
pond-- maybe a huge lake--
and we're on shore and we can't
see the man thrashing around,
we might still be able
to learn that there
was some thrashing going
on, because back at shore
we would see some waves.
So you have to imagine
a really still day
where the pond doesn't have
any waves on it at all.
You're sitting on the shore,
then all of a sudden you
see some ripples come in.
You might be able to
learn from those ripples--
you could put a bob in the
water to measure the ripples--
and you might be able to
learn that there was thrashing
around going on out there.
And if you're really
good, you might
be able to tell certain
properties, like how
big the man was, how
hard he was thrashing,
what frequency, and so forth.
That's really the basic
idea of gravitational waves,
except now, instead of a
pond, we have spacetime.
So you have some thrashing
around in spacetime.
Here we have a pair of
distant black holes--
more on that later.
But they're thrashing
around in spacetime.
And so gravitational waves
go out, and back on Earth
you can try to
measure these waves.
Well, how do we do that?
This is physics.
We clearly need lasers.
That's how you do it.
You build two machines--
one in Washington state,
one in Louisiana--
with big lasers.
I'm going to explain
that in a minute.
But here's a movie, just to get
you oriented to the process.
Two black holes orbit and merge.
A burst of radiation goes
off across the universe.
Maybe it encounters some other
civilizations on its journey,
millions or billions of years.
Finally, the
gravitational radiation
reaches us here on Earth.
So we'll zoom in
to Earth, and you
will see an absurdly
exaggerated movie
of what the waves do to Earth.
They stretch and shrink it.
They distort it tremendously
in this absurdly exaggerated
video.
Here's the burst.
[LAUGHTER]
And then the waves are
gone off on their journey
across the rest of the universe.
Now, those waves were
made by black holes.
But we don't need black
holes to make waves.
I'm going to make
some waves right now.
I am shaking my fist, and I'm
launching gravitational waves.
I'm launching gravitational
waves to the back of the hall.
I am launching them to
the people in the front.
Can you feel the power,
the awesome power,
of the gravitational
waves washing over you?
I'm shaking harder.
I've doubled the
strength of the waves.
I am now changing the frequency.
The waves are now in
resonance with the human gut.
Soon you will feel
very nauseous,
and it will get very messy.
Is anyone feeling nauseous?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So it is true that moving
matter makes waves.
Any motion of matter disturbs
spacetime, sends waves out.
And it is true that
the gravitational waves
stretch and compress and
stretch and compress.
This is among the many things
that Einstein calculated.
This is what the waves
actually do to you.
First you feel a little tall,
then you feel a little wide,
then you feel a
little tall and wide.
And you were all in fact
getting stretched and compressed
by the awesome power of
my gravitational waves.
But you didn't feel it.
So why is that?
Well, for the
answer, we're going
to turn to Einstein himself,
1916, who gave us this formula.
You don't have to worry
about the details,
but let me explain
what the symbols mean.
h on the left is the strain.
The strain is the same
thing an engineer would
talk about the strain on a bar.
It's a measure of how much
stretching or compressing
force.
Here we're quoting the amount
of fractional stretching
or compressing if the bar didn't
have any internal resistance
to stretching, if it were
really just a free-floating blob
of particles and the
gravitational wave washed by.
If this h on the left was 1/10,
then that free-floating blob
of particles would stretch and
compress by 1/10 of its length.
So that's what age the
strain is on the left.
And on the right, with this
i double dot and this D,
you have some measure of
how hard I'm shaking my fist
and how far away you are
from my shaking fist.
But the elephant
in the room here
is the number on this
slide, 10 to the minus 44.
10 to the minus 44
is a number so small
I don't think it comes
up even in physics.
I have never heard of
a number this small.
This number is as if you
took an atomic nucleus
and you lined up atomic
nuclei all the way
across the visible universe.
That would take about 10
to the 44 atomic nuclei.
That number, that fractional
stretching and compressing,
is as if the whole universe
changed by an atomic nucleus.
That is not a lot of
stretching and compressing.
And so when Einstein
saw this, he surely
thought, well, that was a
nice theoretical point I made,
but we are never
going to see these.
This is far too small.
This is just theoretical
physics, never
experimental physics.
Everything changed when
neutron stars and black holes
were discovered in
the '60s and '70s.
If you came last week
to hear Professor Ozel,
you learned a lot about
neutron stars and black holes.
They're unimaginably
dense objects.
A neutron star has
the mass of the Sun
in the size of Manhattan.
That makes the density
of a neutron star
the same as an atomic nucleus.
It's like an atomic nucleus
the size of Manhattan.
It's a totally bizarre object.
But if you took two such atomic
nuclei the size of Manhattan
and you had them orbit each
other at 100 or 1,000 times
a second-- which they can do--
that's a pretty hard
fist shake, right?
That might make some
gravitational waves.
That can turn that 10 to the
minus 44 into a whopping 10
to the minus 21.
[LAUGHTER]
10 to the minus 21 is also
an extremely small number.
And if you're me, you give up.
But if you are one of the
ingenious experimenters
and theorists who thought
up the experiments I'm
going to tell you about
next, you say, wait a minute.
10 to the minus 21--
if I build a
kilometer-scale device,
that's distance changes of
less than a proton radius.
But I think I might
be able to do that.
And Ray Weiss at
MIT drew this sketch
on the bottom left in
an internal MIT journal,
and together with Ron
Drever, Kip Thorne,
and many, many other
important players,
they put together the Laser
Interferometer Gravitational
Wave Observatory, LIGO.
Now, it's a little glib
to do this in one slide
and say 40 years, a billion
dollars, and 1,000 scientists.
So I want to take some
time to really emphasize
how amazing this project is.
As I'm going to describe
in the rest of my lecture,
this experiment has made a real
breakthrough the likes of which
comes along in my opinion,
once every 100 years at most.
This is a real breakthrough.
And this experiment really
was 40 years in the making,
and the National
Science Foundation
and research
universities in the US
provided all the seed funding
for the initial prototypes.
The NSF picked it up and
funded it starting in 1994.
And over 20 years, they kept it
going over changes of Congress,
changes of
administration, changes
of NSF program director.
Everybody had the vision to
see this risky but high-reward
project through.
And we should be proud,
as American taxpayers,
that through our elected and
appointed representatives
we supported this project.
So what is LIGO?
There's two LIGOs.
There's one in Washington state.
There's one in Louisiana.
And you can kind of make out
that there's a lot of tubes.
In those tubes are lasers.
It's the Laser Interferometer
Gravitational Wave Observatory.
Let me tell you why.
This device is called a
Michelson interferometer.
This is something that
here at the U of A
we teach our
undergraduate physics
majors in the second
year of their study.
So it's not
something I can fully
explain in the
next three minutes,
but I can give you the gist.
The basic idea is you
shine laser light out,
you split it up, and then it
bounces off mirrors and gets
recombined.
And then as a wave wiggles those
mirrors, the amount of light
read out changes.
The reason you can do this
is because light is a wave.
Light has peaks and troughs.
And when two beams
of light meet,
if those peaks and troughs line
up, then you get more light.
It's brighter.
But if those peaks and
troughs anti-align,
as shown here on the
right of your screen,
you get no light at all.
So whether the peaks and
troughs are aligned or not
is a very sensitive
function of the distance
the light has traveled
in this setup.
And so as the wave comes through
and wiggles those mirrors,
the peaks and troughs change
their alignment and the light
read out on the right of
your screen changes in time.
That is the light that LIGO
actually measures in order
to measure the changes in
distance of the mirrors
as that gravitational
wave washes through.
Here's LIGO in a
kind of CAD drawing.
It's the same concept, but with
lots of bells and whistles.
These tubes are in vacuum--
it's a very large vacuum--
and there's all
kinds of tricks they
play to increase the power
in the interferometer
and to isolate it
from sources of noise.
That's really the hardest
part of this whole business.
You're trying to
measure distance changes
of less than a proton diameter.
How do you do that when
a truck could drive by
and wiggle your mirrors by way
more than a proton diameter,
or an earthquake could happen?
What do you do?
You need to be isolated from
environmental noise somehow.
And the way they do
it is as follows.
They have this amazing gizmo,
this four-stage pendulum,
which you see the
design for on the left
and some photos on the right.
And this provides two
kinds of isolation.
There's active and passive.
Passive isolation is like the
shock absorbers in your car.
When you drive over a bump, the
bump hits your car pretty hard.
But you don't feel
much of that bump,
because there's springs in
your car that damp that out
and give you a smooth ride.
They use that kind of
passive noise isolation.
And they also use
active isolation,
which is like your
noise-cancelling headphones.
When you put them on
and turn on the power,
they actively cancel out
incoming sound waves.
Similarly, they actively
drive this system
to cancel out any incoming
vibrations in the ground
that it's attached to.
Now, this talk has
a lot of eye candy,
a lot of really nice
pictures, movies.
But I have to tell
you, this is the slide
that still gives me goosebumps.
I remember vividly,
almost a year ago
exactly, when this slide was
released in a press conference
at the National Science
Foundation, which I streamed
here at the U of A for students
and faculty and anyone who
was interested.
And when I saw that
signal, I thought,
oh my gosh, that's a
gravitational wave.
Now, for you, it
may not jump out
to be a gravitational
waves so obviously.
But let me explain to you why.
But before I do that, the most
important thing about this plot
are those numbers on
the top left, GW150914.
That is 2015, September 14--
my birthday.
The gravitational waves
arrived on my birthday.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, universe, for
that birthday present.
OK, that's only the
most important part
of that slide to me.
To the rest of you, let
me take you through it.
First, look at
the vertical axis.
It says "strain."
That's that fractional
stretching and compressing,
and it says 10 to the minus 21.
This is from the
scientific paper.
They did it.
They measured those
wiggles that you
see in red are changes in
distance of a part in 10
to the minus 21, less
than a proton diameter.
The x-axis, the
horizontal axis, is time.
Notice, all this happened over
just a fraction of a second.
And now let's look
at the red signal.
The red signal is what the
device in Washington state
measured.
That's the readout, which
represents the changes
in distance of the two mirrors.
Is that a gravitational wave?
Is it a truck driving by?
Is it an earthquake?
How do we know?
Well, on the second slide, you
see that same data on the right
over-plotted with the data
from the other observatory
in Louisiana, all the
way across the US.
And they line up perfectly.
There's no way that this same
truck drove in front of Hanford
and drove in front of
Louisiana at exactly whatever
it is, three milliseconds
apart, the time
for the gravitational wave
to come from one to the other
in exactly the same way.
They did a bunch of fancy
statistical analysis
to put some numbers to say that,
yes, that's not what happened,
and yes, that's really
a gravitational wave.
But this is why
I knew right away
when they put it up
on screen that this
was a gravitational wave.
This signal was so
loud that you didn't
have to do any of that
fancy statistical stuff.
It just says, wow, gravitational
waves from outer space.
When we physicists try to
understand these signals,
we often convert them to sound.
It's a quick way to
get all the information
about amplitude and frequency.
So now I'm going to
play the sound for you,
and you're going to
hear a bit of a thump.
That's what it sounds
like if you just
take the frequency of
the wave and convert it
to a sound wave at
the same frequency.
You're going to hear
that thump twice,
and then you're going
to hear the same sound
but upshifted into
a frequency range
where your ear is more
sensitive to the features.
[SOUND PLAYS]
Hear it again.
So that little whoop--
we have a name for that.
We call it a chirp.
[LAUGHTER]
That chirp's going to come
back in about 10 minutes,
so let's remember that name.
Let me play it for you
again in case you missed it.
Again, the first thing you
hear is a kind of thump.
That's the actual signal.
And you're going
to hear that twice.
Then you're going to hear
an upshifted version,
then you're going to hear
the whole thing again.
[SOUND PLAYS]
Those are the waves from
a binary black hole,
two black holes that merged
1.3 billion years ago,
1.3 billion light years away.
The waves came all the
way across the universe,
they came to the
LIGO experiment,
and they made that sound.
How do we know these are
actually merging black holes,
like I said?
Well, again, they did a lot
of fancy statistical analysis.
But for this signal, it
was so loud they really
didn't have to.
Again, this is a snapshot
from the scientific paper.
On the top line, you
see the same two plots
that I showed you before--
the data from one
interferometer on the left,
and the two stacked on top
of each other on the right.
On the second line, you see
a theoretical prediction,
a calculation from
Einstein's equations
of what the waves look like
if two black holes merge.
And then what do you do?
You subtract the two.
You subtract the prediction
from the model, and what's left
should just be noise.
And that's on the bottom.
So you see right away
that, what is this?
It's the normal noise in the
interferometer plus a signal,
which is merging black holes.
Now, the way these theoretical
calculations are done
is by a supercomputer.
We take the equations that
Einstein wrote down in 1915,
and we solve them on the
state-of-the-art super
computers.
Here's a simulation
of the orbiting
and merging black holes of
the same size and distance
from each other
that was measured
by the LIGO experiment.
Now, you see the black
blobs and the tracers.
That's just to orient your
eye as to what's going on.
All the interesting information
is in the arrows and the colors
and the shape of the
sheet below them.
That's representing the
curvature of spacetime.
You'll see now the simulation
will slow way down near merger
so you can see just how
distorted spacetime is getting.
It's like a storm in spacetime
as the black holes finally
merge, and there's really
some cusp-y sharp features.
There's a burst of
radiation, and then the waves
are off on their journey
across the universe to LIGO.
Here's another fun video.
This is the question,
suppose we were actually
near these black holes
and we were watching them
in a spaceship.
What would you see?
Well, mostly you'd see
the stars behind you.
And you don't see any stars
from where the black hole is,
because all the light has been
swallowed up by the black hole.
But you also see a very
distorted pattern of stars,
because the black
holes bend light.
So the stars don't look
like their actual positions.
They look very distorted.
And I think we'll just watch
the end of this beautiful movie
together.
Let me tell you
what they actually
measured for this system.
It's not about just detecting
gravitational waves.
It's also about doing
astrophysics, finding out
what's out there.
So how heavy were
these black holes?
How big were they?
The larger black hole
was 36 solar masses,
meaning it had the
mass of 36 suns.
So I've drawn 36 dots
to represent that.
This was reported in
the scientific paper.
The other black hole
was slightly smaller.
It had the mass of 29 suns.
And then they also
measured the mass
of the final merged black
hole, which was 62 suns.
So everything hangs together.
If you take 36 and you
add 29, you get 62.
It's simple arithmetic.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow, you guys are
good at arithmetic.
Yeah, 36 plus 29 is not 62.
It's 65.
What happened to those
three suns of mass?
Where did they go?
Believe it or not, all of
those three suns of mass,
the weight of three
suns, was radiated away
in pure energy carried by
those gravitational waves.
This is e equals
mc squared energy,
Einstein's other equation.
Right?
Except if you think about the
normal way we use e equals
mc squared energy-- you know,
something really impressive,
like atomic weaponry--
atomic weaponry releases
some tiny fraction
of the e equals mc
squared energy inside
your warhead, which
is not the mass of the sun.
Here you're releasing
all of the e equals mc
squared energy of three suns.
That is a ton of energy.
And you're releasing that in
just a fraction of a second.
And in fact, during
that fraction
of a second when these
black holes merge,
they're releasing more
energy per unit time.
They're brighter than the whole
rest of the universe combined.
As theorists, we knew this.
Einstein's equations
are well-established.
We know how to solve
them on computers.
We can calculate that when
you merge a 36 and a 29
solar mass black
hole, you radiate away
three solar masses of energy.
And we talked about this,
but now we've actually
observed it happen in nature.
It's fantastic.
Another really fun
part of LIGO's story
is this amazing signal
I've been telling you
about which arrived on my
birthday, September 14,
we almost missed.
The LIGO experiment decided
to start their observing run
on September 12.
And the founder of LIGO, Ray
Weiss, was dragging his feet.
He said, oh, it's
not quite calibrated.
We don't want to start.
Let's get it perfect.
But the younger crowd
convinced him to go for it.
And we're glad he did, because
two days after they turned it
on--
this thing's been in the
works for 20, 40 years--
they measured this
spectacular signal.
They saw something
else in October,
which was probably a signal--
they're not sure yet--
and then another
confirmed one in December.
Then they took the
experiment down,
upgraded some of the optics,
improved the seismic isolation,
and they're observing again now.
Already, just from
one measurement,
we learned a little
astrophysics.
First of all, we learned that
black holes can find each other
and merge.
That's not obvious.
Predictions for how many
black holes there would be
and how often they would
merge were all over the map.
Now we have tight
constraints on that.
And we really
discover a new type
of black hole, because
previously, from x-ray studies
there in the purple, we
knew there were black holes
of around 10, 15 solar masses.
And from other studies, like
what Professor Ozel told you
about last week, we knew
there were giant black holes
of a million solar masses.
And now we know that
there are also 40
and 60 solar mass black holes.
So that's the weight
of these black holes.
What about the size?
Well, to set the scale,
I'll give you a map
of the Eastern United States.
I think that's the part I'd like
to blot out with black holes
right about now.
[LAUGHTER]
There's the signal I've
been telling you about.
That's how big those
black holes are.
There's the candidate
signal, and there's
the smaller black holes
that were also measured.
So these are state-sized objects
with the mass of 30, 40, 50,
60 suns.
LIGO is just the beginning.
We have two detectors, LIGO
Hanford and LIGO Livingston.
Those are the ones that
made the detection,
but there are many more
detectors around the world,
either operational, coming
online, being built or planned.
And in five to 10 years,
we should have all six
of these detectors working.
In Germany, the GEO
detector; Virgo in Italy;
LIGO India in India,
and KAGRA in Japan.
It's great to have
more detectors,
because gravitational waves
are a little bit like sound.
You don't really know where
a sound is coming from.
If you have two
ears, you can sort of
tell where it's coming from,
but not very precisely.
If you have three
ears or four ears,
you could start to
tell more precisely.
And if you have six
ears, you can really
start to get a good
handle on where
that sound is coming from.
So if we have six
detectors, we can really
tell where in the sky the
gravitational wave is coming
from, and we can tell our
astronomer friends, hey,
go point your
telescopes over there.
You might see
something interesting.
When we have these
six detectors--
and even before-- we have
a lot of fun ahead of us.
We're super excited
about the first signal
we saw, merging black holes, but
we're going to see a lot more.
I'm sure LIGO has already seen
more black holes, although they
don't tell people
who aren't officially
in the collaboration.
But I've heard rumors.
There are supernova explosions.
When stars end their
lives and explode,
they make these
giant explosions.
That probably makes some
gravitational waves.
We'll hope to observe those.
My personal favorite is
merging neutron stars.
Again, a neutron
star is matter at
the density of an
atomic nucleus.
We don't know very
much about matter
at the density of
an atomic nucleus.
So we're going to learn
a lot of nuclear physics
if we can start seeing a lot
of merging neutron stars,
because those waves
carry information
about the process of merging.
We'll see rotating
neutron stars.
And perhaps most excitingly
is the question, question,
question mark on the
right, because we've really
opened a completely new
window on the universe
here with gravitational waves.
And every other time in the
history of astronomy that we've
gotten a new way of
looking at the universe,
like when radio astronomy
started or x-ray astronomy
started, every time
there were expectations,
and there were huge
unexpected discoveries.
So perhaps most
exciting are the things
we don't know about that we
will discover with this new way
of seeing the universe.
I'm going to change
gears a little bit
and tell you about
my own research.
I work a lot on
gravitational waves,
and one question
we asked recently
was, what if a black
hole spins really fast?
You can spin a black hole, and
you can spin it really fast.
You can't spin it at
the speed of light.
Nothing can go
faster than light.
But you can get it really,
really, really close,
at least in principle.
So here's the sound
of a wave form
that is from a
normal black hole.
This is theoretically generated.
We just made this
on our computers
as part of the research.
But this is just a
comparison signal
for what a normal black
hole merger sounds like.
[SOUND PLAYS]
Right at the end there,
there's that [SOUND EFFECT].
That's the chirp.
Chirp is the hallmark,
the calling card,
of merging black holes.
All the theoretical predictions
have always predicted chirps.
And that's what LIGO measured.
But when we got one
of these black holes
spinning really fast, when we
finally cracked the mathematics
to let us explore this regime,
something very interesting
happened.
It starts the same,
but you're not
going to hear a chirp from this
rapidly spinning black hole.
[SOUND PLAYS]
It just sits on a single
note, and it fades away.
We call that a song.
[LAUGHTER]
It's very different.
It's not [SOUND EFFECT].
It's [SOUND EFFECT].
[APPLAUSE]
So why is this exciting?
Well, in astrophysics,
we don't have
great ways of measuring how
fast these black holes spin.
But now we can tell
that if you hear
a sound that doesn't chirp--
it just sings-- you're
looking at a black hole
spinning really,
really, really fast.
Now, we gave this
black hole a nickname.
And our scientific
paper has a funny title
up there on the right,
"Inspiral into Gargantua."
If you've seen the
movie Interstellar,
there's a black hole
called Gargantua.
And it turns out, for
the plot of Interstellar
to make any sense at all,
that black hole Gargantua has
to spin very rapidly.
It has to spin with
99.999999999999%
the speed of light, 14 nines.
So, is Gargantua out there?
How would we know?
Well, if the next thing LIGO
hears, or some other experiment
in the future, if the next
thing they hear is this song,
then we've discovered Gargantua.
When I started thinking
about this problem,
I wasn't thinking about
astrophysics at all.
Rapidly spinning
black holes turned out
to be a really good
theoretical testing
ground for the following sort
of pure theoretical physics
question that I'd like
to describe for you.
It's called the black
hole information paradox.
At the start of the
talk, I gave you
a paradox involving the speed
of light being the upper limit
that you can physically go, and
this formula, v is v1 plus v2.
That paradox was
resolved 100 years ago.
This paradox is
still with us today,
and it's really driving
theoretical physics,
I'd say more than
any other paradox.
In its simplest form
the question is,
can you tell what was
thrown into a black hole?
So these are thought
experiments, not
real experiments.
But we used to do
them with cats.
We would throw the cat
into the black hole.
And then we started
feeling bad about that,
so now we use graduate students.
[LAUGHTER]
That seems to go
over a little better.
But in these thought
experiments--
not real experiments--
we either throw a cat in
or a graduate student in,
and then we ask you
to come back later
and look at the black hole.
And can you tell--
in principle, not in practice--
if it was a cat or a graduate
student that I threw in?
Einstein's theories say no.
The black hole-- anything
that goes into it
is, for all intents
and purposes,
gone from the universe.
You will never be able to tell,
in principle, whether I threw
in a cat or a graduate student.
But there's another
theory of physics
that you'll hear about
a lot more in two
weeks with Professor
Cheu's lecture, which
is quantum mechanics.
And all the
formulations of quantum
mechanics that we know
about have a fundamental law
that information is preserved.
In quantum mechanics,
you have to be
able to tell, in principle
if not in practice,
whether it was a cat
or a graduate student.
So there's a fundamental
tension here.
And it's really Stephen
Hawking who first pointed this
out after discovering
some fantastic
properties of black holes
that made it very apparent.
His paradox is really
still with us today.
Now, I did not solve
this paradox, alas,
when I was thinking about
rapidly spinning black holes.
But it led to a new
prediction in astrophysics,
which just shows the
interconnectedness of science.
In the last few minutes, I want
to take a step back and think
about where in the history
of science and astronomy
this gravitational
wave discovery lies.
You may know that
light is just one
wavelength of
electromagnetic radiation,
and radio and microwave and
infrared and ultraviolet
and x-ray and gamma ray
are other wavelengths
of electromagnetic radiation.
There's a whole
electromagnetic spectrum.
Astronomy really began
when Galileo first
turned his telescope
to the heavens,
and among other
things, discovered
the moons of Jupiter.
You can see his sketches there.
There's Jupiter with four
little moons that he observed.
Since that time, we now
have astronomy in all
of these different wavelengths.
In radio astronomy, we've
discovered incredible things.
That was the discovery of
neutron stars, in fact.
Up there in the top left, that
speck there is a whole galaxy.
That galaxy is
shooting out particles
moving near the speed of light
in a straight line for hundreds
of times the galaxy's size until
they make this beautiful plume
that we see in the radio.
Some of my other
research is aimed
at trying to understand what
the heck is going on there.
In the microwave, we
can see light left over
from after the Big Bang.
13 billion years ago when
the universe was just
a hot plasma--
no stars, no planets, just
hot plasma, no elements even.
In the infrared, we
can see galaxies,
learn about their structure,
trace them through cosmic time.
In the visible, well, we've
come a long way since Galileo.
Now if we look at Jupiter with
our best instrument, the Hubble
Space Telescope, we get
that beautiful image.
That's not a painting.
That's a picture of Jupiter.
In the ultraviolet
we can see the storms
on the surface of the Sun and
learn about plasma physics
at high temperature.
These coronal mass ejections
that wipe out communications
here on Earth-- we can study
those, among other things.
And in x-ray and gamma ray,
we see the high-energy events
in the universe.
The gamma rays sky looks
like that big image
on the upper right
there, except every once
in a while when there's a bright
flash called a gamma ray burst.
Those gamma ray
bursts were actually
first discovered by
military satellites
looking for Soviet
nuclear tests.
But they pretty
quickly figured out
that the gamma rays
they were measuring
were actually coming
from outer space.
The origin of those gamma rays
is still pretty much a mystery,
and it's a mystery LIGO
might help unravel.
But that's the
electromagnetic wave spectrum.
Gravitational waves
also have a spectrum.
And where are we in
observing this spectrum?
Well, we're just like
when Galileo first pointed
his telescope to the sky.
We've made one observation.
It's tremendously exciting,
these merging black holes,
but it's one observation
at one tiny frequency
band in this whole spectrum.
As LIGO becomes more
sensitive, we'll
start to hear higher
frequency things--
maybe supernovae and
merging neutron stars.
There are space-based
detectors in the works that
will measure the monsters of
the universe-- supermassive
black holes, black holes with
millions or billions of times
the mass of the Sun.
There are other
detectors that get us
to even lower frequencies, where
we might hear cosmic strings--
or if we're very lucky,
gravitational waves
from the Big Bang itself.
Let me summarize.
I started the
evening telling you
about how a century
ago Einstein discovered
a deep new reality of
interconnected space, time,
and gravity.
He discovered new
things about physics.
Those consequences of Einstein's
equations were revolutionary,
and they are still
with us today.
And 100 years later, one
of those consequences
has now been turned into a tool.
We are now using Einstein's
gravitational waves
to hear the universe in
a completely new way.
And in closing, I want to
leave you with two questions.
What will we learn
in the next 100, 200
years with this new astronomy?
And what will be the next
revolution in space, time,
and gravity?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]